almost everything in chemistry needs
catalysts to work but some of them are
running out a lawyer two studies
surfaces Gerhardt Ethel's work has
already proved crucial in the fight to
clean up our environment I really like
Atlas right this basics on capella this
which really fundamental and important
and I really like learning the
fundamental science behind how catalytic
converter works
a laureate who runs a lab which invents
vitally needed new catalysts is Robert
Grubbs that's the prettiest ruthenium
complex I've ever seen I was going to
disagree I think girls is a better
chemist than artists
you
a catalyst is something that helps speed
up a reaction it makes it go faster and
the way that it works is what we study
as scientists like how does it make it
go faster well it helps those molecules
orient or brings them together or makes
them want to react with each other
catalysts are absolutely crucial but
supplies of those based on rare metals
such as rubidium palladium and platinum
and not unlimited there is a potential
shortage do you think there's a problem
do you think we can solve it it's a
problem is caused mainly by effects smed
come from China yes and say for monopole
energy is 0 so if the market would be a
more open this I think there would be no
shortage anymore it's a more political
issue not a scientific issue but what
happens when non developed countries or
developing countries start to become I
guess just more developed and say you
have a lot more drivers and a lot more
cars and now we have a lot more
catalytic converters what's that going
to do to our supply of say platinum and
palladium and rhodium for things like
catalysis and synthetic chemistry should
synthetic chemist be worried about using
a platinum palladium rhodium for other
applications there are strong efforts to
replace the noble metals by oxides of
less noble metals so far not with very
much success sorcery azores it's still a
lot of research has to be done there
yeah yeah and you know in the synthetic
area and people are trying to move from
platinum palladium technical and in our
area where we're in the ruthenium thing
we're trying to switch to iron but you
know so you know I think those are the
directions people are trying to go in
but again chemistry controls what you
can do so I'd like to just set up a sort
of very hypothetical contrived situation
let's say we have absolutely no more
palladium platinum rhodium ruthenium
these types of metals what are we going
to be affected by what happens to the
earth what happens to our standard of
living around the world
perhaps we'll have cars which are not
running with gasoline that's right and
there was buttress hydrogen fuel cells
and said you have no exhaust errs and
perhaps you don't need to catalyst
anymore so but few sites are also
running on platinum usually so yeah
perhaps you'll find my dessert medals
for that as a materials for the
electrodes that sounds like a actually a
really fantastic world and thinking
about emissions and global warming and
problems with carbon based fuels so
should we really be pushing people to
not use these kinds of metals because
the world that you just described sounds
pretty advanced and fart so we're not
ready for it apparently Robert grubs and
Gerhard ertel don't seem to have a
problem it's a problem I really thought
at the outset that they were going to
say you know really push hard really try
to drive your science toward abundant
metal so things like iron things that we
could just dig up out of the ground
anywhere but they didn't say that at all
and so maybe it does it maybe it sways
my opinion a little bit about what we
need to do as chemists in order to make
really efficient catalysts and I still
see that it might get a problem about
politics and about yeah how to get there
I mean not about the amounts but I have
the feeling that it could just get a
political problem I mean for oil now
there are political issues there are
almost worse sometimes so could it be
that you also said that for example a
teeny more rare earth metals are mainly
mind in China or in African countries or
something but maybe this might also be
some political interferences then we
might not run out of platinum and
palladium or rare metals but China could
really restrict I mean the u.s.
especially because we import a hundred
percent of our rare metals yeah well we
platinum palladium Kabul comes mostly
from South Africa it's the other where
is sorts of think I come from China
young yeah I can understand that young
people are concerned about these
problems but there are other problems
which are much more serious it's a
moment say energy crisis and
environmental issues there are more more
demanding and looking for solutions
since its supply of previous match
materials so in regina's catalysis is a
basis of chemical industry and one of
the most important catalyst reactions
was to have a bush process the formation
of ammonia from elements nitrogen
hydrogen and the figure shows the
variation of the world population and
the variation of the production of
ammonia over time and you see there's a
close parallel et there's an estimate
said one third of the world population
would staff without cease reaction I
loved your presentation the other day
because i'm studying nitrogenase for the
same reason of wanting to make catalysts
that are more efficient because
nitrogenase is able to catalyze nitrogen
into ammonia at room temperature and
ambient pressure whereas the haber-bosch
process is very high pressures and very
high temperatures and its really
interesting that scientists have been
studying this problem for a really long
time you said yourself that it took 70
years to understand the mechanisms right
yeah it was going on on solid surfaces
why did it take so long to figure out
the mechanism even though we use it so
readily catalysis is complicated
especially surface catalysis where
you're dealing with very small amounts
of material surface States and you
really hope develop the tools which
allow us to allow us to sort of look and
understand before it was just total
edisonian I used to consult for people
in industry who do heterogeneous
catalysis and you know you talk and they
would say I did a little barium and it
got better so I added some more they got
better what should I do next and you
know you had we're barium who knows why
but it works so it used to be a black
ops like rocking right in some ways it
seems like it still is there are a lot
of people in subfields of chemistry are
still just kind of mixing and seeing
what happens it's almost impossible from
fundamental research and predict how you
can increase your productivity by one
percentage is this trial and error
sometimes you can have surprises gold
gold was considered to be completely
inactive
yes until some researcher from Japan
found that very small / layers of record
became Activia so to two monolayers of
gold are a catalytically active in this
very hot topic in research why just a
small amount of CO goalies Activia so I
think there will be in a surprise as
well these other materials which just
have to work on it he take information
from where you can get it it used to be
a black art for more than 100 years
because almost nothing was knowing about
the mechanisms underlying sick chemical
process taking place on Anna catalysts
we know much more but we still don't
know everything about the different
parameters which are influencing the
catalytic activity talking about
combustion we have been burning things
here a very very long time and we still
do not understand everything about it
course not about all these pearls are
very complicated yeah combustion seas
are many different reactions chain
reactions and then we take place with
reticle sin so it's not just
transformation of one molecule in nasa
banyo i didn't realize it was so complex
so i'm still pretty new PhD which is why
i'm so enthusiastic well were you say
the two zs t he ceased over enthusiastic
about but to come back to the idea of
nature catalyzing things at ambient
temperatures and pressure and they've
had millions of years is that the end of
the continuum we reach a point in which
we have very complex systems which we
can use very abundant metals maybe in
some cases we will other cases will
still have to use platinum and palladium
you think so yeah if you just think of
ammonia sins as a catalyst works for up
to 20 years right that's right the
natural catalysts undo do is they i
replace their continuously it is there
yeah yeah yeah so we have to be better
than nature catalysts research is
considered to be the basis for the
solution of our environmental and energy
programs related also is a global
warming it's quite obvious that in the
future
action will be the source of our energy
demands here because we have enough
sunlight only less than 1% of the
sunlight is needed and the conversion of
energy from the Sun into other materials
which can be stored catalysis will be
the key for solution of these problems
the best thing that the US could do for
carbon footprint would be to teach China
out of frac so so they could convert
their cold power plants into natural gas
that's what 30 that's a good idea what
else are you going to do they're gonna
burn coal yeah but there are changes I
mean the people are changing now and
they are looking for sustainable energy
and I think it's not a good i mean if
the people are saying let's do fracking
but well let's do it in some country
where we don't care no no let's I mean
that's not not making sense and even
especially China I mean they have
platinum they have where's mess but
they've got lots and lots of coal and
they need energy so they burn coal yeah
but but we could I mean if we want to
teach them something then I would say
it's a good way to teach them how to do
catalysis how to use their rare earth
metals which they have but that doesn't
help them get around eat their houses
run their air conditioners live the
lifestyle they want to live yeah but it
can I mean account Alice's like like you
can teach them arcade used sustainable
energy then use this energy to produce
for example hydrogen use the hydrogen to
to to use X electricity in you I I think
we get there eventually but I don't see
us doing that short-term short you know
we've got to get through the next X 15
years until we get all this stuff built
up but i think it's pushing it pushing
it as soon as possible with the best way
because just saying okay as long as we
have coal and as long as we have all
just left using it but i think it's so
much more valuable to use it for
chemicals and if we once run out we
cannot use it for other things anymore
completely agree with you i completely
agree but but that's the task of the
scientists who do really 2mon but it's
also the question whether you're a
pessimist or an optimist that's right
yeah really yeah if you look back in
history whenever there was a serious
problem man could never come that's
right yeah yeah that's right so I'm
convinced that the real comet right yeah
I mean I would love if China quit
digging coal but they're not good in it
then I mean they are then digging maybe
playing or other fly latium well another
dig in platinum and palladium 2 well you
know but China actually now has one the
largest solar programs going or develop
an incredible rate or developing wind at
an incredible rate but it just not
keeping up which all requires a rare
metals feather yeah yes actually I do
yeah in my opinion the word is really
going for renewable energies and web we
can do this and that this will be not
something in hundreds of years but that
will be something in my life span and he
wishes saying come on relax this is not
realistic and I don't believe that it's
going i said ok let's do fracking and
all the self and i can't just accept
this and I I'm really forcing and saying
okay we can do this we just have to want
it Bob Grubbs was like sort of i agree
with you but right now no one wants to
pay the cost for it so it comes back to
the economy but i really like you're
really pressing it yeah he was kind of
being the devil's advocate because he
was like i would love for that to happen
it's not gonna happen and then so you
were like no it's gonna happen there is
this area in organic chemistry called
organic catalysis which is using organic
molecules as catalysts for things and so
that's been going for years but now it's
really become a focused focused area and
with a title land but it's more limited
right because it has to be so much more
complicated than you more organized more
thought out well i don't know i mean
we've you know are some pretty
organizing or thought of it methyl it's
always in north no no not always no no
some of them are very clean you know
they tend to be lower turnovers and much
more catalyst loading and stuff but
they're pretty simple i have no medals
to get rid of at the end is it
conceivable that we'd ever use such a
catalyst for producing chemicals and an
industrial scale oh yeah yeah i mean
there's there's
Anna catalyst now Athena don't think we
shift our attention away from rare
metals we can keep working with rare
metals and flatten em video we gotta
solve problems however we solve them
yeah we can use what we have oh my god
let's plan for the future but we've got
to get through right now and maybe at
this our turn maybe it just goes over to
us to say we are still yet we have the
power we have the feeling and we have to
enter the atom I sort of agree right and
so they've laid scientific foundations
they're sort of giants in our field and
so at some point they really have to
pass the torch on there the younger
scientists and they seem to be very good
at laying out the problems for us and
being like you have many tools at your
disposal and these are the problems and
so we just need really passionate you
know people to go out and try to solve
these problems
you
you